foreign
season's about to end how's the season
been treating you got a definitive top
10 list already as we've often learned
from anime all it takes is one episode
should be watching or stuff that I find
excellent this season I'll give you my
list of fights because everyone loves
anime fights right right the views on
some of my videos speak for themselves
and I'm here driven to give you guys
what you want so without further Ado
here's my personal list of the best
fights this season has to offer let's
start off with a quickie from Dan
machi's ongoing season eyes versus
asterius
thank you
eyes has consistently been one of my
favorite danmachi characters ever since
her introduction with that in mind more
eye screen time that shows us how cool
and badass she is is always a win in my
book well in episode 8 of dunmachi's new
season we get to see some of the better
stuff as she takes on asterious eyes
holds her own with her flashy techniques
and we actually see some impressive
shots in between some admittedly spotty
animation throughout the sequence of
events still gave me a good feel for the
atmosphere and I found myself caught up
following the action for a short
Skirmish the fight was good and I think
that it can be one of the good ones of
this season overall I like what I saw
but I think I might be biased and the
fight itself is a quickie with a rather
inconclusive ending and that's why it
just finds itself at number 10 on this
list
[Music]
we then proceed with iska and Alice's
first fight together in kimisen ah who
doesn't like a good old battle couple I
just enjoy the chemistry between iska
and Alice it's an awkward relationship
given the Romeo and Juliet nature of the
setting but they just work so well
together the first major challenge comes
from someone who's not a slouch 2 a
powerful ancestor of the witch race the
two find themselves in a bind early on
being outmatched by the sheer power of
the founder however the strongest power
doesn't come from individuals but from
Hearts United and fighting as one it's a
pretty cliche asop and all but I just
can't help but have a soft spot for it
but how much I love the two main
characters the fight itself finds itself
just near the bottom of the top 10 list
it's a fight that becomes a lot better
based on the context and the Showcase of
powers but the actual fight doesn't blow
anyone out of the water
oh come on
foreign
taking on the usna forces and Lena when
looking at fights it's really hard to
grade godsuya fights by the result of
the stakes because we all know he's
going to come out on top most of the
time I mean look at it this way we have
quite a literal anime Jesus on our hands
so I just end up laughing whenever I see
these Americans scheming to beat him
while tatsuya fights typically lack
tension they often make up for it with
impressive choreography and animation
and such can be seen in episode 7 of
mahoka's second season there's just
something so sweet seeing him break down
and dissect all futile attempts by those
pesky Americans tapping off with a
second Showdown against Lena now armed
with a brand new weapon sorry everyone
no one trumps tatsuya the fight did give
us though a badass visual of datsuya
putting his gun right in front of
brionak on route to the easy victory
oh
[Music]
fireforce for me has always been a treat
to watch because of its animation ever
since season one it had its fair share
of moments and battles that are just
awesome the second season's no exception
to that and I think that my favorite one
so far is the flame infernal nadaku
fight in episode 16. for me Ensemble
fights versus some Kaiju thing are good
if they can show the teamwork and how
the characters work together this one
has tension but that's not all Ensemble
versus Kaiju fighter to be judged with
for me they work best if the stakes are
upped and the goal is not just to beat
some big scary thing but to fight it
with a certain level of care and in this
case the goal of rescuing nadaku we also
got a backstory after this battle that I
really enjoyed this one's a nice marker
to a key moment of an arc in my opinion
somewhere near the bottom half of the
list seems fine as I find it one of the
best battles this season has to offer
foreign
[Music]
King's Avatar is a weird series not
weird in terms of the actual content but
for all the Fanfare it had thanks to
Word of Mouth the series has quite
Fallen Into Obscurity with its movie in
second season as I've often said I find
that quite regretful because if anything
the current season's been picking up
where the first one left off in terms of
fight excellence and an example of that
would be yishu's dude against Wang in
The Season's fourth episode it's a very
engaging fight this is two new Peak form
duking it out it's not just a duel of
power however it comes down to speed and
technique I've played some intense
jewels of my own in video games and this
battle just shows some of the best parts
of those the reflexes the
resourcefulness and all those things
that you need to come out on top this
fight evoked those emotions and I find
myself enjoying it a lot because of that
burn the witch may be a one-time deal as
of now but it did give us some good
action in the form of its final fight
I'm looking
one other guy's current reception I
think the burn the witch has become
quite underrated maybe it's exactly
because of the fact that it's a one and
done movie that doesn't really have much
in the way of setting up the world but
as far as its presentation of a bleach
first take on a world like Harry Potter
it's a fun movie that I think does
deserve a watch and ends with a good
fight that gives me some flashbacks of
the good old bleach days with the pretty
obvious brimjao tribute character and
our two protagonists fighting one of the
Legendary Dragons It's really an uphill
battle and I find myself at the edge of
my sea anticipating what the characters
can do to get out of this bind at least
we get to see what our girls can do but
no way can people like them take out one
of the Legendary Dragons right well
turns out that uncle's a lot stronger
than we all thought overall it's a fight
that's carried by the talk and the story
developments that happen in the middle
of it instead of the choreography I
think it's the perfect ending for a
standalone movie like what they're going
for with burn the witch
[Music]
drive has blown up quite a bit these
past weeks now hasn't it I wouldn't say
it was at the bottom of the popularity
rankings when the season started but it
did seem to take quite a backseat to the
harder hitters of the season from
various genres not anymore and I think
this fight has a lot to do with it if
there's a surprise of the season in
terms of how intense an action-packed
its fight scenes can be it has to be
akudama Drive I mean it really seemed
edgy at first glance but I didn't expect
something like this a fight that blew me
away in Surprise given how everyone
reacted I don't think that I'm alone
here it's such a badass fight that I
can't help but hop onto the hype train
for the episodes to come
[Music]
here's something a bit nostalgic
boruto's 175th epic proud
not quite topping the list but a fight
that I'd be inclined to put on top would
be Gojo vs jogo
foreign
the fight that caused the internet to
explode Gojo has a serious case of being
The Season's most overpowered and
awesome Mentor character and this fight
showcases him at his best as far as what
we have in anime form after seemingly
getting overwhelmed and having his ass
handed to him Gojo decides that play
time is over and when he says so he
means it the blindfold comes off and we
get a look at his stylish and handsome
face before he proceeds to rip jogo a
new one literally such a stylish display
capped off with such a decisive finish I
think if I was to make you vote this
fight would probably shoot its way up to
the number one spot I did give it some
serious consideration too and I think
that the next one barely edges this one
out as it wasn't as one-sided
below milestone